- When did style first become
a big deal in your life?
'Cause I know you love style.
(dog barking)
And you look stylish right now.
- Thank you,
you know I grew up in New York.
And I think that New York has that kind
of influence on you.
You know you walk down the street
and when I was a kid
growing up it was really,
I would see Andy Warhol.
- Yeah.
- You know walking down the street.
You know and I,
and I always appreciated style.
I would look at like "GQ Magazine"
and dream about being
on the cover one day.
And I was with Tom Hanks
and Will Smith years later.
But when I was a kid,
kid I would sell stolen
polo shirts on 14th street
out of a box.
(group laughing)
- I love it this is like confessions.
- Yes and I would carry the box around
on 14th street and I'm dreaming about,
you know one day I'm gonna
be on the cover of the GQ.
And one day I can afford to
actually wear these clothes.
And I don't know how it's all gonna work
but I know I can do it.
But in the meantime I'm
selling used stolen shirts.
- I love it,
I love it.
We all had our weird things we did before.
- Yes, yes, absolutely.